Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Nando's in the UK and India.
This is "Food Wars."
If you're ordering chicken for one person,
it comes in three sizes at a UK Nando's.
As a quarter chicken,
as a half chicken,
or as a whole chicken.
Chicken for one person
here at Nando's India
comes in the form of
a quarter chicken, which is one piece,
or a half chicken, which is two pieces.
You can also get a whole chicken,
but it only comes in the
form of a sharing platter,
the largest of which is a jumbo platter,
two whole chickens and five large sides.
I'm excited to eat this, but
all I need now is friends,
so hit me up.
The largest item in the
UK is the family platter.
It comes with two whole chickens
as well as five large sides.
Family of one.
I could eat this.
What about some other things
from the Nando's menu?
Well, in the UK, you can
get a grilled chicken burger
in two sizes.
As a single or as a double.
Nando's India also sells chicken burgers
and offers customers the
option to double their chicken,
so you can get a single chicken burger
or double it to a double chicken burger.
Nando's India serves chicken wings,
but only in one size, a pack of four.
Wings from a UK Nando's
come in four portion sizes:
as a three-piece,
as a five-piece,
as a 10-piece,
and a 15-piece.
It's really weird being the country
with the bigger sizes for a change.
Joe, I miss you.
Now, the classic side for any
order of Nando's in the UK
is a side of peri-peri chips.
I'm allowed to call them chips, not fries,
because Joe is not in this video.
In the UK, these come in two sizes,
regular and large.
Here at Nando's India,
they're advertised not
as chips but as fries,
because that's what they
are, Harry, you weirdo.
I'm going to weigh them.
You get them in two sizes,
either regular or large.
Let me weigh the regular.
It's 100 grams on the dot. Nice.
Next.
418 grams.
No, 408 grams.
175 grams in the large.
I don't know how to read.
Here is everything on
the menu at a UK Nando's
that you won't find in India.
This is everything you'll find
on the menu at Nando's India
that you will not find in the UK.
We'll start with the chicken.
Now, when you order chicken at Nando's,
they'll ask you to pick a spice level.
We have quite a few of these,
most of which are shared
with India, except for two.
Firstly, we have pimento spice.
I think this is limited edition,
and it sits somewhere
between medium and hot
on the spice scale.
And our other exclusive
spice is peri tamer.
As the name suggests, this
is quite a mild, tame spice.
It sits somewhere between mild
and basically plain chicken.
I think it's a slightly sweeter glaze
than you might find on the
regular peri-peri spice.
Here in India, we just get our chicken
in the classic scale of plain,
lemon and herb, mild,
hot, and extra hot.
I'm willing to bet that our extra hot
blows the UK extra hot out of the water.
You see this tongue?
This tongue can take spice.
Oh, my God, is this some kind of joke?
It's, like, tickling me.
It's teasing me with spice.
This is child's play.
I will say, I love how the UK
Nando's has two extra flavors.
I wish India Nando's experimented more.
We're in India, dude!
There are so many spices!
But what we lack in spices,
we make up for in mains.
No. 1, creamy cashew
chicken with spicy rice.
Damn good.
OK, now on to the next main.
This is chicken cataplana.
Cataplana is a type of Portuguese
clam-shaped ... stove? Cooking pot?
And they've also served
it with a yogurt dip.
So using a cataplana
is apparently healthier
because you end up using less fats
to cook your meat and your veggies.
Next up, we're having chicken espetada,
or, as I like to call
it, chicken espe ta-da!
I've been fired from this
show 16 times this season.
I imagine they take the pieces of chicken,
put them on skewers, put the marinade.
So, Nando's is a Portuguese-inspired
South African restaurant,
so most of the recipes are
things that were developed
by Portuguese explorers when
they were in South Africa.
We also have a lot of
cuisine that's inspired
by our former colonial
overlords back in Portugal.
In fact, Goa, which is our
smallest state here in India,
was where the Portuguese first settled,
and so a lot of the cuisine is derived
and inspired by Portuguese cuisine.
We have a couple of
chicken mains of our own,
starting with boneless thighs.
These come in orders of
four, and you can get them
in any of the standard
Nando's spice levels.
And our other chicken exclusive is this,
wing roulette.
So, wing roulette is an order of 10 wings,
and it's a variety of the Nando's spices.
The idea is that you'll get some of these,
share them with your friends,
some of you might get hit
with an extra-hot wing,
whereas others might get
off easy with a mild.
When I go to Nando's, I'm
generally going for medium or hot.
I'm not trying to be a hero.
If I'm going for extra hot,
I'm just not actually
going to taste the food.
It's just going to kind of hurt.
I may also add a little bit
of the garlic and herb sauce,
which adds a little bit of spice to it,
or also I've used ketchup in the past,
which my friends have lambasted
me for, so don't do that.
Good chicken, though.
We also have some meal deals.
These are more affordable options,
and you will not find them in the UK.
Let's start off with the first one,
which is pulled-chicken sliders.
Oh, my God, this is like gourmet dining.
I think I would need to eat three of these
to feel considerably full.
Unfortunately, they only give you two.
Next up is a pulled-chicken burger.
Oh, my. Mother lode of chicken.
That is a lot of pulled chicken.
It needs a sauce.
Did I just eat a part
that doesn't have sauce?
Next up, we have chicken tigela,
which is basically grilled
chicken, some corn,
some roasted veggies, and tomato,
and this is served with some spicy rice.
They've also given a bunch of veggies.
Nando's is really trying
to get our vitamins in.
But take a look at the tigela itself.
It's got a bed of rice underneath,
but on top there's some pulled chicken,
a lot of grilled onions,
and a lot of finely chopped capsicum.
Next up, you have the option
of a pulled-chicken wrap.
I mean, it looks like a wrap.
Or you can also get a pulled-chicken pita.
Damn, this looks like a doner kebab.
I guess the true test of whether Nando's
is putting a lot of effort into their food
is whether their wraps
and their pita taste good.
Let's go.
Miles better than any
other fast-food restaurant.
Alongside those, you can
get a tub of veggies.
So, next up is chicken skewers,
for a kebab-eating nation.
Good job, Nando's.
You get these along with some pita bread
and a couple of salsas.
You get a yogurt sauce and some salsa.
Next up, we have Portuguese
chicken and gravy,
and if you can't tell from my face,
I'm having a great time.
Ooh, boy!
Look at that.
It looks like there's tarka
on top, dude! Oh, my God!
What is a tarka, you ask?
Basically it's the best way
to finish off a curry here in India.
We take oil, heat it,
add some spices in there,
temper them, and then
pour them over our curry.
And our final meal-deal dish
is saucy chicken strips in spicy rice.
I'm not gonna lie,
this one looks like the most boring option
out of everything here.
Let's look at some of the
burgers and wraps from Nando's.
In the UK, we have a couple
of exclusive options.
Firstly, we have the Sunset burger.
If I had to hazard a guess as to why
this is called the Sunset burger,
it might be because you kind of get
a sunset yellow, orange, red effect going
with the cheese, the
chicken, and the chutney,
which looks very pretty.
I haven't had this before.
I wouldn't normally order it at Nando's,
but it's actually very, very good.
The bun is slightly different
to the regular burger buns that we get.
It's a little bit more spongy and pillowy,
and that chutney stuff is delicious.
Very sweet, little bit smoky.
Then we also have the fino pita.
I really love the packaging of this.
It's great for delivery.
You just tear straight through the middle,
not like that,
and then pop that off.
You have a nicely preserved upright pita.
Now, on a fino pita,
you get chicken thighs,
you get some salad, you get
perinaise, you get halloumi,
and I think there's also
some caramelized onions
in there as well.
I'll be honest. If I'm going to Nando's,
this is what I'm getting.
It's kind of got all my
favorite Nando's things
in one little package.
They took it off the
menu for the pandemic.
They've recently brought it back,
which I am thrilled about,
'cause I've missed it dearly.
The cheeky Nando's level's
off the charts right now.
We have a couple of exclusive burgers
and wrap flavors of our own,
starting with the chicken
Caesar salad wrap.
I kind of like that packaging.
Let's see how this tastes.
That is a messed-up way to eat a wrap.
Eat it from the top, not from
the side, please, Nikhil.
Wow.
Next up is the peri cheeseburger,
which also comes as a
wrap or in pita form.
Look how the juice is
dripping off this thing, man!
That's what I'm talking about.
This flavor has just taken India by storm
in the past few decades.
It's part of the trifecta of ingredients
that are red velvet, matcha, and peri-peri
that people just love to put
into every menu over here.
Peri-peri, if you don't know,
is a spice mix that was
discovered by Portuguese explorers
when they were settling/pillaging
south African countries, like
South Africa and Mozambique.
On the subject of
foreigners coming to a place
and taking things from it,
I would like to formally
apologize to India from the UK.
Feel free to come and take your stuff back
from the British Museum
whenever it's convenient.
I feel like most Indians
identify peri-peri
as the little packets of
peri-peri you get at McDonald's,
and you pour them into your fries
and shake them to get peri-peri fries.
I feel like when they come to Nando's,
they might find it not spicy enough.
If you don't eat meat, Nando's
is actually pretty good
for vegetarian and
vegan options in the UK.
First up, we have the Great Imitator wrap.
It doesn't look very appealing right now.
However, the Great
Imitator is Nando's version
of fake chicken.
I think it's made with pea protein,
and by all accounts, I've
heard it's pretty good.
Then we have the Beanie burger.
As the name would suggest,
it's a bean patty.
Also comes with, I believe,
an egg-free mayo, some salad as well.
Then we have a spiced chickpea burger.
It's kind of similar to
the Beanie burger, however,
once again, as the name would suggest,
the patty is predominantly
made of chickpeas.
This one actually mirrors the
Sunset burger a little more
because it's got the same bun
and also has some of
that red-pepper chutney.
And then finally we have
a portobello mushroom
and halloumi pita.
It's a pita bread with a big
portobello mushroom inside
as well as some salad, some halloumi,
and more of that red pepper chutney.
Pretty much every fast-food
restaurant here in India
serves vegetarian food,
because a huge percentage of
the country is vegetarian.
Having said that, Nando's actually had
quite a few non-vegetarian options,
which is very cool to see
in a restaurant like this.
So let's go off the list
of vegetarian food now,
starting with creamy cashew
paneer and spicy rice.
So, this is the same thing
as the creamy cashew chicken,
except they've replaced it
with chunks of cottage cheese,
and it just looks delicious.
Let's see if Nando's
has done paneer right.
It's really nice, and it's not as chewy.
It's soft. Soft paneer
at a fast-food chain.
Unheard of.
The next vegetarian dish
is called Something Exotic.
Ooh! It's a mystery.
Even they don't know what it could be.
And it is ...
What the heck?
I did not expect to see this.
It's watermelon and paneer.
You know, Nando's, watermelon and paneer,
you really are walking the line between
creativity and abomination.
No. Those are kind of weird together,
but I think overall this is a fun dish.
And they serve it along
with a three-bean salad.
The three beans are chickpea,
rajma, and some other one.
Let's taste.
Even this is flavorful. What's going on?
OK, now we're moving on
to a vegetarian version
of the cataplana.
They have tossed the same vegetables,
but this time along with
paneer and some chickpea.
I'll only taste the chickpea.
Very nice.
This is easily the best food
I've had on "Food Wars."
Hands
OK, next up we have a vegetarian version
of the espetada as well.
Look at this!
This is probably the best veg
skewer I've seen in my life.
It's just too beautiful, I can't eat it.
I must frame this in my home.
Also, they serve it with garlic bread,
because this isn't enough apparently.
The first one is a veg burger.
They serve it with coleslaw.
It's a run-of-the-mill frozen patty.
It's all right.
This is probably the
most underwhelming thing
on the menu so far.
And finally, they have a
mushroom and paneer burger.
Both of these options you can
get along with a wrap or pita.
They have put
a huge chunk of paneer in there.
Have you seen a paneer this big?
I didn't even know they made this s---.
Superb burger.
When there's good food in
this show, I'm so happy!
And that's not all.
There are more vegetarian options
from the meal-deal section.
Let's go from the top.
First off, we have veg sliders.
These ones have patties
instead of pulled chicken.
Next up, you can get a veg
tigela. This one has paneer.
So, same thing, it's a bed of rice,
some chopped veggies on top,
but with paneer as the protein.
It's served along with potato wedges.
Next up, we have paneer
skewers that you can get
along with either spiced
rice or with some pita bread.
Very similar to the skewers
we had with chicken,
and they seem to have
the same sauce as well.
They're served along with either
pita bread or spiced rice.
You can choose which option of side,
and you also get a salsa
as well as a yogurt dip.
I always feel like it's hard
to do skewers with paneer,
because it's such a delicate ingredient
that if you fry it too
much it gets too rubbery.
Oh, is that a piece of
pineapple there? Oh!
There's a lot of thought
put into these dishes.
Nando's is a class apart.
It's just a class apart!
And finally, we have a very
simple option at the end.
It's roasted veg and some grilled paneer.
I'd probably skip this one.
Next up, the UK exclusive starters.
First up, we've got
some sweet potato wedges
and garlic perinaise.
For some reason, they've also mixed in
a bunch of regular chips as well.
I don't know if that's normal,
because I'm traditionally
not going to order sweet potato fries.
If you've watched "Food
Wars" for a long time,
you will know my thoughts on sweet potato,
namely that they are bad.
It's just like someone
took a chip and went,
"How can we make this floppier?
I know!"
The garlic perinaise, however, very tasty.
Would recommend getting a side of this
next time you're in Nando's.
Also exclusive to the
UK are peri-peri nuts.
You can start your meal off
with a combination of, I think,
cashews, almonds, and
maybe macadamia nuts,
all coated in their
signature peri-peri spice.
I'm usually pretty good at this.
Let's find out.
In the UK, you can also
get fried halloumi sticks
and a dip of your choice.
However, unfortunately,
the restaurant forgot ours.
Here's what they're supposed to look like.
Neither of these are exclusive,
but in both countries,
you can also start with hummus and olives.
India has a variety of options,
starting with the cheesy fiesta fries.
Seems pretty straightforward,
but let's see if it is a fiesta.
Oh, my God. Bro, their
presentation is off the charts.
Look at this. Look at this.
Everybody marvel at the presentation.
OK, I will say
these have been in the cold for a while,
so they may not taste as
good as when they're fresh.
And I am right.
Next up, they have cheesy fiesta chicken.
Boom!
It's pulled chicken,
grilled onions, same cheese,
and I imagine there's fries underneath.
Next up, they have something called
the sweet potato and corn snack.
Whoa! Why is their food so beautiful?
There's corn, there's bits of red paprika,
some chopped parsley,
but also it's pieces
of thinly sliced lemon.
That's new.
Oh!
Are you supposed to eat that?
It's interesting.
I don't know if I'd serve
lemon pieces in my salad.
Next up, we have four-piece wings,
but these ones are spicy, tangy wings.
They look quite delicious.
I'm going to sprinkle some lemon on there.
I'm disproportionately jealous
of that little lemon wedge with the wings.
Why don't we have that? Very little touch.
Lovely bit of freshness to your wing.
Forget about it.
I have to be honest. Pretty bland.
Not tasting any spice,
not getting any tang.
These are the most underwhelming
things on the menu so far.
And now for something
I did not expect to see
on the Nando's menu at all,
we have a creamy cashew
paneer and chicken naan.
More like Naando's.
Am I right, guys?
Bro,
why is all their food looking like art
that I can hang up on my wall?
OK, so this naan has the chicken,
so this is the naan-veg naan. [laughs]
Let's go ahead and take a
bite, see how it tastes.
It's damn good.
The gravy on top is very
similar to a butter chicken.
It's got a lot of sweetness and richness.
You can tell there's cashew in it,
but they've also sprinkled
on a lot of green chili,
some coriander, and chopped onions,
so there is a nice kick of spice,
and they just drizzled
a lot of malai on top,
so it's creamy.
This is what it would be like
if India had to have a pizza.
Banging.
Also, they serve it with
something called perinaise dip.
Are you sure this is for this?
Let's just avoid.
It's just, like, a huge tub of mayonnaise,
but it's perinaise, apparently.
For those looking for a healthier option,
Nando's also offers salads.
There are two main options in the UK.
Firstly, we have this quinoa
and peri-tomato salad.
This actually looks pretty
good, I have to say.
It looks like kind of sun-dried tomatoes,
some lettuce, some dressing,
some of these little crunchy
crouton-cracker things,
and, of course, quinoa.
And our other salad option
is the delightfully named
rainbow bowl.
Now, the very colorful rainbow
bowl comes with some hummus,
some coleslaw, some tenderstem broccoli.
There's some grains down in the corner
and I think some shredded carrot as well.
I love tenderstem broccoli
and will fight to the death
for tenderstem broccoli.
By default, the salads come plain,
but you can also add chicken
breast, chicken thighs,
fake chicken, or Beanie
patties to any of them.
Here at Nando's India, we
have salad options of our own,
starting with the Mediterranean salad.
Ooh la la! Opa!
Is that something Mediterranean?
Next up, we have an Algarve salad.
Looks pretty much the
same, minus the olives,
plus some cashew nuts and a lot of
sun-dried chili or tomatoes.
Then we have a quinoa salad,
for those of you who are monsters
and can't eat rice like a normal person.
And finally, we have a Caesar salad,
and the Caesar salad
comes with a dressing.
Now, all of those salads
we ordered are vegetarian,
but you can optionally
get some chicken strips
if you need more protein in there.
Then we're on to the sides.
In the UK, you can get
quite a few exclusive sides
to go along with your peri-peri chips.
First up, we have rainbow slaw,
which is coleslaw filled with Skittles.
No, it's not. It's just coleslaw.
But kind of colorful.
We also have a mixed-leaf salad.
Little box of leaves.
Oh, there's some tomato and
cucumber in there as well.
This one is spiced grains
with butternut squash,
which actually sounds pretty good.
Some grains in there, I
think that's feta cheese,
some green beans, and butternut squash.
Next up, we have creamy mash potato.
It's mash potato.
You can also get a side of
just some long-stem broccoli.
This one looks a little
more sad than the one
that was on the salad, but still great.
I think there's some garlic
in there as well. Nice touch.
And then finally we can get macho peas.
Peas for macho men, just like me.
I wasn't really sure where to put these,
but there are a couple of extra things
which you can add on to
pretty much any order,
so I guess they kind of count as sides.
First up, you can just
buy a couple of pieces
of grilled halloumi from
a Nando's in the UK.
For those of you who don't
know, halloumi is a cheese
which I think is made with
sometimes a mixture of
sheep and goat's milk,
predominantly produced in Cyprus.
It's an interesting cheese.
When you bite into it,
it doesn't really give. It's
got a kind of rubbery texture.
I personally find it
very satisfying to eat,
as do a lot of British people.
I think we're responsible
for something like 80%
of the Cyprus halloumi
consumption in the world,
which is kind of wild.
But, yeah, it's pretty good.
It, like, squeaks on your
teeth when you eat it.
The other sorts of side options include
just one whole portobello mushroom.
This might have looked OK when it was hot.
You can also just get a single
plain tortilla from Nando's.
I guess the idea is that you could buy
maybe the halloumi, the mushroom,
and a couple of other bits and sauces
and create your own wrap
or own burrito situation.
Personally, I don't think
it's worth doing that.
Just buy a preassembled one.
Options for sides here
at an India Nando's,
you can get potato veggies.
I already showed -- veggies?
No, no, they're not veggies,
they're potato wedges.
Run-of-the-mill potato wedges.
You can also get some chargrilled veg.
In fact, they give you a lot.
You can also get a three-bean salad,
which looks really colorful
and has, like, a soupy
liquid that I want to try.
Lentil soup, you say? Nay.
I want three-bean-salad water.
Next up, we have a Portuguese salad.
Looks pretty straightforward.
I have no idea what makes this Portuguese.
Is it the olives?
Probably.
And finally, you can just
get a tub of feta cheese.
They gave me six cubes of feta cheese.
Yeah.
Cool.
Nando's actually has quite
a few dessert options
in the UK. If you're in-store,
many of the shops will have an option
for bottomless frozen yogurt.
So you can have that in
the flavors of vanilla,
strawberry, chocolate, or mango.
In-store and also on delivery, you can get
a few more options,
including a Naughty Nata.
This is Nando's take on a
Portuguese egg-custard tart,
aka pastel de nata.
I've probably butchered
the pronunciation of that.
If I take myself out to Nando's
and I'm feeling bougie,
I'll probably end my
meal with one of these,
'cause I love these things.
We can also get a salted caramel brownie.
Look at that. It's very pretty.
It's got little gold sprinkles on it.
I'm describing more foods as pretty.
Been the theme of today.
But they are kind of pretty.
Next, we have a Choc-A-Lot cake,
which is a slice of what looks like
a pretty good, gooey, kind
of indulgent chocolate cake.
Pretty moist.
And then we also have this
gooey caramel cheesecake.
This is actually really good.
I'm a cheesecake fan,
but this is a great
example of a cheesecake.
I had it for the first time, I think,
when we filmed the UK versus US Nando's.
Go watch it now.
Highly recommend.
We don't share any desserts with the UK,
but we have our own
desserts, starting with
an ice cream and hot chocolate,
but they don't deliver it,
so here's an image of it, I guess.
Looks pretty good. Looks nice.
Then we have a series of cakes,
starting with a chocolate cake.
It's parceled in a burger case,
which is kind of weird,
but, dude, look at this.
Thick, moist, fat cake.
I must taste for science.
Appropriately humid.
Next up, a red velvet cake.
What did I say?
The trifecta of ingredients.
I'm surprised there's no matcha milkshake
at the end of this.
They have to fit in red
velvet in every restaurant.
Peri-peri, red velvet, and matcha.
And finally, we have an
out-and-out cheesecake.
Honestly, all of these desserts are OK.
I'd probably skip the dessert here.
Last, but by no means least,
let's talk about the drinks.
If you go into a restaurant
of a Nando's in the UK,
you can get bottomless fizzy
drinks, including Coke,
diet Coke, Coke zero, Sprite, and Fanta.
Now, some people will ask
for a free glass of tap water
and then use that at the
fizzy-drink fountains
to help themselves to free fizzy drinks.
But I personally have
definitely never done that
and would not encourage
that kind of flagrantly
illegal behavior whatsoever.
On delivery, we do also have
a few exclusive drink options.
The first options are
these Bottlegreen cordials.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with cordials,
it's like a flavor concentrate.
So what you'll do is you'll
put a few splashes of this
into a glass, top it up with water,
and then you have a drink
that you can actually consume.
I kind of thought these
would come premixed,
so I was a little bit surprised
to see just bottles of the cordial itself.
But I guess you can make
yourself some squash at home.
This is roy-boss. Roy,
roy, roy-bows. I don't.
[whispers] I don't know
how to pronounce this.
Rooibos teas, which are
flavored with things
like lemon, peach, and berry.
And finally, we have
Gingerella, by Karma Drinks.
This is just a ginger ale.
We can also get bottomless
soda refills here in India,
but our bottled options
are fresh lime soda
and two iced-tea options.
I don't know if fresh lime
soda's a big thing abroad,
but over here in India
it is the No. 1 drink for
middle-class families.
When you go out with your family,
each person of the family
has a different order
for fresh lime soda. Some
like it with just salt,
some like it just sweet,
some like it with sweet and salt,
and some monsters like
it with no salt or sugar.
This is from a company called Brewhouse,
a tea-brewing company.
This is supposed to be
a mojito lemon iced tea.
It's nice.
And next, a peach iced tea.
Nando's also offers these
drinks called designer drinks,
which seem to be nonalcoholic
soft-drink cocktails.
It seems like they just
took 7Up and blended them
to form different flavors
with different colors.
But I'm curious to see if
they actually taste good.
Color, color, which color do you choose?
Let's try the virgin mojito.
Ah, tastes like a mojito
without the alcohol.
You can see they've gone the extra mile.
They've put in fresh lemon,
a lot of mint in there.
Next one is citra,
which I assume is a
mandarin/orange-flavored drink.
Oh, nice.
Very delicious. Super refreshing.
I thought this could be something
we could make fun of Nando's for,
but they've actually made some
delicious, refreshing drinks.
Ip dip do, the cat's got the flu,
the dog's got the
chickenpox, and so have you.
Portuguese lemonade.
Let's go.
What makes it Portuguese? I don't know.
Maybe it's olive oil. Let's see.
This is really yum.
So, it's not all sweet.
It has some sort of powder at the bottom.
Is it peri-peri powder?
I don't know, but it
tastes like chaat powder
that they put in a lot of
lemon sodas here in India,
and it's really yum.
Peach and elderflower.
They actually put a
slice of peach in there!
These are certified designer drinks.
Half a chicken, peri-peri chips,
and garlic bread at a UK Nando's
will cost you £13.10.
That same meal in India
will cost you rupees 800.69,
which at the time of filming this video
is equal to £9.85.
That's almost 25% cheaper of
a meal than the one in the UK.
OK, now while you Brits
might feel hard done by
because of these price differences,
I must say that this is
actually super expensive
for a single meal for a
single person here in India.
In fact, most people in this country
would find that almost aspirational.
You can get meals here
for close to 100 rupees.
That's less than a pound.
I would say that I can't
even consider this fast food.
It is the most expensive
restaurant we've tried here
on "Food Wars," but the food
was top class throughout,
so I guess it makes sense.
Now, Nando's does have some
slightly more affordable options
in the form of meal deals,
where you can get a single
meal for around 400 rupees,
which is equal to £4.50.
This doesn't seem like
a significant upgrade,
and it isn't.
In fact, the state that
we're filming this video
is Karnataka here in India,
and the daily wage is around 500 rupees.
So you would have to
literally work an entire day
to afford a single meal here at Nando's.
In fact, my first salary as an intern
was 10,000 rupees per month,
which is £125 per month.
And so if I ordered a "cheeky Nando's,"
it would literally be nearly one-tenth
of my entire monthly salary.
I'm not sure I'd consider Nando's
an affordable option in the UK,
and I'm not even really sure
I'd consider it fast food.
It sits somewhere in that
kind of fast-casual bracket,
combining elements of
fast-food restaurants
with elements of the more
traditional dining experience.
Some Brits don't really like Nando's
and might claim that
it's kind of overrated.
I personally love Nando's.
It's fast, it's consistent,
and I have a kind of
cultural attachment to it,
as I was kind of a teenager
when it really blew up
in popularity here in the UK.
I might be able to get
more value for money
at somewhere like a KFC, but to me,
it wouldn't hit the same.
Unfortunately, Nando's in the UK
doesn't disclose a full ingredients list.
Nando's in India also doesn't disclose
a full ingredient list.
So what do we know about the food?
Well, the FAQ pages on
our respective websites
do share some clues.
For example, in the UK,
Nando's says it uses Red
Tractor-assured chicken
from British farms. To
be Red Tractor-certified,
chickens must be raised
with certain benefits,
such as no cages and natural light.
The Indian FAQ page says
that all of Nando's chicken
in India is sourced from
India, and it's all cage-free.
They also say that all
the chickens are A grade.
Now, I don't know what this means,
because it's hard to keep up with
up-to-date poultry
practices here in India,
but one report from 2012
said that a top-grade chicken
must be "free of deformities that detract
from its appearance or that affect
the normal distribution of flesh.
Slight deformities,
such as slightly curved
or dented breast bones
and slightly curved backs
may be present."
Now, this sounds kind of vague,
but I do hope that Nando's
is following this practice
and only sourcing some A-grade chickens,
'cause that's what it tasted like.
Some A-grade chicken.
One other thing we can
glean from the FAQ page
is that the Great
Imitator wrap might not be
as plant-based as Nando's
seems to think it is.
This is because both the tortilla wrap
and also the glaze used on
the chicken contain shellac.
Shellac is a substance used
in food as a glazing agent,
but it's found in various other things,
such as nail polish,
fireworks, and sealants.
The twist is that it's
technically an animal product.
It's a resin secreted by lac beetles.
Female lac beetles will
secrete it onto trees
in the forests of India and Thailand,
where it's then harvested,
processed, and sold for use.
Do bugs count as animals
for the purpose of veganism?
I'm a meat eater, so I can't
really talk, but in my opinion,
I don't think a bug should
count. I think that's fine.
Hey, everyone, its Harry Kersh
from the "Food Wars" team.
I finally got to meet my cohost Joe Avella
for a cool new project we're
working on called "Food Tours."
Here's the trailer for it now.
Joe: Oh, yeah?
Harry: It's so good, man.
This thing is incredible!
Oh, my God!
Harry: Can I shock you, Joe?
I quite like this.
Oh, yeah!
Yo, what's up with that egg
over there? What is that?
Harry: That's the Gherkin.
Joe: [laughing] What is it really?
Harry: That's literally the Gherkin.
Joe: That's not the Gherkin.
People of the internet,
you cannot expect me to
pick this up with my hands.
Harry: Oh, ho, ho, man.
You know what, Harry?
Up till now, I didn't get the
whole "cheeky Nando's" meme,
but now I kind of get it.
I feel like they're having a lot of fun
with all the food that they're serving,
and I had so much fun
eating all of the food.
I feel like India should
have its own version
of the cheeky Nando's.
We're going to call it the charlu Nando's,
because charlu means
kind of cheeky in Hindi.